c'était super 61 52 % pour le binôme
geoffroy backs de keating clarisse de
mon contre 38 48 % pour le duo david
jutier patricia milo les candidats
europe ecologie les verts n'ont pas
réussi à faire vaciller la majorité
départementale sortante
la liste ensemble pour les yvelines a
conservé lors de ce second tour des
élections départementales le canton de
rambouillet ça a été compliqué mais
voilà on y est arrivés on a fait une
belle campagne je pense une campagne de
terrain où on n'a absolument rien lâché
on a été sur le dernier mois partout
dans les gares dans les marchés on ait
été auprès de tous les habitants des
suds illinois et donc on est vraiment
très fier de cette victoire qui était
pas non plus actes et donc on est
vraiment très fier on aller chercher les
voix une par une
et donc maintenant ça promet le meilleur
lors du premier tour geoffroy vexe de
keating des clarisses demont était déjà
en tête dans ce canton du sud yvelines
mais les écologistes david jutier et
patricia milo n'était pas très loin
derrière laissant un espoir au binôme
entre déception et satisfaction c'est la
consternation devant l'abstention qui
dépasse encore ce soir les 60 % qui
restent à ce niveau record qui interroge
vraiment sur la légitimité des personnes
qui sont élus ce soir avec une
représentation aussi faible des
habitants et habitantes de la de la
population et puis évidemment un
sentiment de satisfaction parce que
élection après élection on consolide nos
scores et on montre que sur le sud
yvelines sur le canton de rambouillet le
projet politique qui est porteur d'un
espoir d'alternance de renouveau c'est
bel et bien l'écologie politique et ça
c'est la reconnaissance du travail qu'on
fait depuis maintenant 10 ans hurle sur
le terrain après l'annoncé officielle
des résultats pour les soutiens du duo
gagnant
lajoie s'est fait ressentir dimanche
soir comme pour le président du sénat
gérard larcher venus spécialement
félicité le binôme de p y
malgré l'abstention victoire très clair
une victoire très large dans toutes les
communes du canton d'une équipe dhabi
nom'' à la fois marqué par l'expérience
clarisse de vaud
la jeunesse l'enthousiasmé le nouveau
maire du perray-en-yvelines c'est je
crois
l'image que nous pouvons donner à la
roquette aussi d'un certain nombre de
nos concitoyens qui n'ont pas senti
qu'il était important de se déplacer et
pourtant le département c'est la vie
sociale
le département ce sont deux aînés le
département ce sont deux collèges le
département c'est l'aménagement de
routes au quotidien et je dois dire que
ce travail là il va falloir qu'on le
fasse encore plus demain
mais une très grande joie je suis ravi
des résultats puisque deux des candidats
font partie de mon équipe municipale
madame demont et monsieur gourland je
suis heureuse de voir malgré
l'abstention qu'il ya encore aujourd'hui
que de nouvelles personnes se sont
mobilisées objectif maintenant continuer
son action pour clarisse de monde et
apporter de la nouveauté pour le tout
nouveau conseiller départemental
geoffroy texte keating